you guys don't know this but sometimes I
like to do these vlogs in different
voices for example this is a tyrone the
40 year old compton reformed thug
what's up [ __ ] tyrone always
says [ __ ] for some reason that's
my toilet paper [ __ ]
oh what is going on you little hoochie
coochie cutie
now one of the hardest things I had to
fix was my habit of constantly going out
to eat now when I say this I'm not
saying that you're not supposed to go
out to eat that's just stupid but when
you go to these restaurants without any
nutritional fats it's kind of hard to
fit these foods into a healthy diet so
for me with restaurant unless somebody
really asked I try to avoid that [ __ ]
like the Black Plague cuz you ever
noticed that the moment you start
cleaning up your eating habits suddenly
everybody wants to go out to eat David
you own diet yeah fried chicken with a
side of bacon that's my favorite I don't
know what it is but every time you're
trying to better yourself there was some
jackass and it's planted into your life
they're trying to [ __ ] it all up and
listen I'm not trying to blame someone
on the fact that I have no self-control
that's all on me it's called
self-control meaning is the control the
goddamn self but if you are my friend
and you know that I am weak to Fried
Chicken why friends don't tempt friends
with fried chicken that's a biblical
that's paniculata Thessalonians 4:17
check it listen I'm gonna kidding you
the benefit of the doubt you want to
invite me out to eat because you don't
want me to feel left out right you is
afraid that I'm gonna text you oh it's
like that
TFT eye [ __ ] friends listen thank you
but [ __ ] yourself listen your intentions
are great but you are inviting a man out
to eat food who looks at a cheeseburger
like a crack rock you know most
criminals will probably rather
McDonald's for the cash I would just
take them for the food you [ __ ] put a
hundred nuggets in the DA you know what
you're setting me up friends and
sometimes I think y'all do it on purpose
because every time you do it you always
say some [ __ ] like you want to go
out - ah I was just testing you
are you so funny how about I testing a
time bomb up your [ __ ] let me put it
to you like this
you might as well just tell an alcoholic
listen I'm gonna leave this beer in
front of you in this hot-ass room but
don't you drink it ha ha
give me that beer yeah you know what
time I told myself I was gonna get fit
so I decided I was gonna do 100 crunches
I don't remember too much but I do
remember an hour later I woke up on the
floor with a sandwich and a Cappy Sun in
my mouth
well funny fat fit we got another day
and another workout coming at you what
today's workout is going to be the
Stairmaster what up now what is the
Stairmaster you ask the Stairmaster is a
machine that flips you over and sticks
of pipe up yes no but at all honestly
the Stairmaster is exactly what it
sounds like it's a machine that
replicates walking up stairs stair
master cuz it's gonna own your [ __ ]
ass no no a lot of you out there hit
running me included so what I do is dead
is this machine right here it [ __ ]
hurts it's a great workout get your
sweating as hell and gets that heart
rate up like this now straight up this
machine and I have a love-hate
relationship it's a great workout but
ever since I started working with this
machine I don't think it's gotten any
easier you know sometimes it burns so
bad I like to pretend like I'm going you
know in Lord of the Rings and I'm going
to Mordor mr. Frodo but yes that
concludes this episode of funny fat fit
and remember funny fat fit then life is
always what you make it but it's up to
you to take with you deserve let's go
for broke
Oh what is going on YouTube now that
concludes this episode of funny fat fit
once again I apologize because last week
we could not do funny bad fit it's
because I brought out that where that
sketch I did yours gonna be on the left
and right over here you know I'm fan
yeah yeah
Nikes version of just do it a lot of you
been asking why did I do it in Korean
because just do it and cannot get it's
funny because you know can young get is
such a harsh thing and it's you you know
I don't whatever baby laughs it didn't
make you laugh chalky dig um ah but
remember we still have the Korean Nike
commercial part 2 coming up this Sunday
and we have funny fat fit after that so
stay tuned Sunday and Wednesday
yes I will see you out there peace out
bazooka load it up with what spy my
[ __ ] document just closed on me
like that punk-ass [ __ ] here we go you
see that I've upgraded member before I
had that little plastic chair thing
going on I got this plush pleather